et parmi les mesures mises en place
depuis la rentrée pour éviter un
brassage trop importante des élèves au
lycée il y à ce système hybride qui
propose des cours en distance yale en
alternance avec des cours en présentiel
soit l'accueil se fait par demi classe
soit par niveau c'est à dire une semaine
les secondes puis les premières et les
terminales un casse-tête organisationnel
qui est devenu une habitude au modèle
ville cette semaine au lycée descartes
de tours ce sont les élèves de seconde
et de première qui sont présents dans
les murs
deux tiers des effectifs soit environ
700 élèves
ici chaque niveau du second cycle et
donc absent des locaux une semaine
toutes les trois semaines en
enseignement à distance
il est vrai qu'avant c'est - à -
pratique que d'être que d'être dans
l'établissement donc on a pu avoir des
remarques sur quelques quelques ratés
techniques au début lorsqu'il fallait
mettre en mettre en place mettre en
oeuvre les l'enseignement à distance en
utilisant les outils de vision une
visioconférence voilà donc et parfois
quelques ratés on a pu nous de notre
côté prêté des ordinateurs grâce aux
prêts qui ont été consentis par la
région d'après ces pandas prêtés un
certain nombre d'ordinateurs aux élèves
qui en étaient dépourvus
dans l'enseignement privé catholique
quatre mille deux cents élèves sont au
lycée dans le département répartis dans
onze établissements
l'idée générale est que plus
l'établissement est proche de la
métropole plus les élèves doivent faire
de l'enseignement à distance
il y avait des établissements qui seront
présents ciel 100% d'autres qui sont à
50 % 60 % il n'ya pas c'est souvent lié
à l'historique des établissements les
locaux il est beaucoup plus facile
d'accueillir des élèves dans des
structures où il ya pas mal de place que
dans des structures en particulier c'est
du centre-ville qui sont plus denses au
niveau population donc c'est surtout ça
qui pose des difficultés pour l'accueil
en présentiel à 100% ou même à 80%
difficile de croire à un retour à la
normale d'ici le mois de juin pour les
lycéens restent des inconnus
parmi lesquels la tenue des épreuves du
bac